what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be digging
into the latest events in the black
clover story
including yuno's intense training arc
and what appears to be a brand new devil
form
for osta black clover has been
absolutely crazy lately and it's all
building up to a massive final showdown
against the dark
triad the clock is ticking time is
running out it's
absolutely epic so let's get into it
if you enjoy the blacklover content here
on the channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like
and comment it really helps a lot and if
you're new to the channel or maybe you
just haven't subscribed yet make this
the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
i always say this but you really have to
go through the trouble of hitting that
bell and then selecting the option that
says
all if you don't do it you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers we're talking
about the very latest info
in the manga so please proceed with
caution you have been warned
the new installment of the story starts
off with yuno who is undergoing his
own training arc at the same time that
austin liba
are trying to fight knocked at first
yuno is training by himself and working
hard to perfect his win magic
he's like straight up leaving massive
craters in mountains
with his wind magic which is insane but
then langris shows up langris is of
course
finral's brother and a man who is
currently going through his
own little redemption arc juno seems to
be determined to train on his own
and he has already planned out a
strategy to take xenon down
yuno definitely has a lot to prove and
he is determined to make up for his
failure to protect his fellow golden
dawn members
earlier on as the current vice captain
of the golden dawn
yuno is willing to do whatever it takes
to make xenon pay for killing
multiple members of his squad and of
course yuno is willing to do whatever it
takes to save his captain william
however while just training on his own
yuno has been unable to actually confirm
how effective his planned strategy
against xenon will end up being
in a real battle conveniently though
langris possesses spatial magic
just like xenon or rather xenon's devil
so languras might be the perfect
sparring partner
for yuuno langris can help yuno test out
his
anti-xenon strategies in real time
which could prove to be extremely useful
in the actual battle
once that battle comes and even though
yuna would prefer to train by himself
he recognizes that this is an issue that
involves the entire
golden dawn squad not just himself as a
result
he accepts language has offered to train
together
and this definitely shows that juno has
matured as a person
and as a vice captain even though he
normally keeps to himself and focuses on
perfecting his own abilities
this situation calls for a different
approach
at the end of the day this isn't about
yuno and his personal pride
his captain's life is at stake the honor
of the golden dawn
is at stake and the memory of juno's
fallen comrades
is at stake you know then shows that he
is willing to put his own personal
feelings and his own personal pride
aside for the greater good
and of course langris has been moving
towards becoming a better person ever
since the elf saga
so i do think that these two are going
to make great sparring partners
both of these guys have something to
prove and both of them are extremely
powerful magic
knights now when we last left the battle
between
asta and liba vs knocked liebe was in
his chibi form
and asta was on his feet and ready to do
battle
asta was using yami's katana as his
weapon of choice
and according to the official viz
translation the name of that sword
is now the demon slasher sword
so the demon decapitator name was just
the unofficial name
even though i honestly prefer it to the
demon slasher sword
i mean slashing is something that
literally any blade can do
and decapitator just sounds cooler but
hey
that's just me anyway since the end of
the previous chapter
the situation has changed drastically
asta and liba are no longer on their
feet and ready to do battle
in fact they are both flat on their
backs
and down for the count oh and liba is no
longer in his
chibi form it seems that noct has been
absolutely crushing them over and over
again
and based on what's been happening so
far asta can't even imagine a scenario
in which he and liba could
actually win knocked is absolutely
dominating the fight and he isn't even
using his full power yet
so at the moment the situation seems
pretty hopeless for asta
and liebe because austin liba are unable
to access that devil union mode that
knocked can access with gimodello they
simply can't compete with
noct's level of power but their training
isn't over
yet after eating some food that heals
their injuries and their stamina
asta and liba are ready to fight once
again
and asta seems to have a brilliant idea
for how they can fight
more effectively asta gets liba to
literally sit on his shoulders so that
the two of them can fight together as
one
liba thinks that asta has to be joking
but asta says that no
fighting like this may actually force
them to work together in new and more
effective ways
i mean this looks pretty hilarious under
the circumstances
and liebit doesn't really buy it and
then some pretty hilarious
awkwardness and bickering ensues as liba
and asta argue about what their strategy
should actually be
knocked warns them that their training
time is almost
up it's already been two days
and noct decides that now is the time to
take
drastic measures asta and liba
will either finally manage to defeat him
or
they will die trying in that moment
knocked unleashes his devil monozone and
everything around them is
covered in darkness not only is it pitch
black and austen liebe can't see
anything but they also can't sense any
kind of key
or presence in this darkness which means
that at this point there is no way for
them to anticipate
or dodge knocked attacks asta and libis
suddenly find themselves in a position
of
absolute fear and hopelessness it seems
that they are about to die
without fulfilling their most important
goals
which are of course saving yami and
avenging lichita's death
and this moment of utter desperation
awakens something within the two of them
asta and liba refuse to die here
they refuse to let yami die and they
refuse to leave their goals
unfinished and their dreams incomplete
a small spark of light breaks through
knocked pitch black
monozone and as knocked looks on an
absolute shock and it's really a
surprise to even see knocked reacting
this way
a new power awakens within asta
a new power that seems to be changing
asta's
eye the heavy implication here is that
we have a brand new
asta devil form most likely asta's devil
union form
his assimilation of his devil liba
it seems to me that noct deliberately
orchestrated this moment of desperation
this feeling of hopelessness and
imminent death within
asta and liba in order to basically
force
this new power to awaken within them i
know that we met knocked only recently
but i am sure that he wasn't actually
planning on killing them
i'm sure that he had everything planned
out perfectly and this exact
outcome was his intention from the start
that said the most likely scenario is
that
osta just assimilated liba into his body
temporarily
like knocked a simulated gimmodello
earlier using his devil union mode
canis if this is indeed the case then we
can expect
asta to take on a new physical form just
like noct did
and we could expect asta to unlock new
powers
and abilities and i expect these
abilities to be
a major power up because there is no
more time for training
the clock is ticking and yami's life is
in imminent danger
as such i think that this new form will
make
asta exponentially stronger although it
probably will have some limitations
for example i imagine that he'll only be
able to use it for a certain amount of
time before reverting back to his normal
form
and after everything that we've seen in
these past few chapters
i think that this is the perfect way to
handle asta's power up
we all knew that asta needed to get
stronger somehow
and quickly in order to play an
important role in the fight against the
absolutely overpowered
dark triad but at first we didn't know
how
exactly asta was going to get so strong
so quickly
after everything we've learned about
liebe and asta
and their connection after the two of
them realize that they share the same
goals
and aspirations and that they have the
same type of determination when it comes
to doing the right thing
for their loved ones actually having
asta and liba unite as one
in a new form is the perfect way to
symbolize their newly developing
bond their training isn't over yet
but i think that austin liba have just
unlocked a new
form and a major new power up and i
can't wait to see what this new form
looks like and what it can do what do
you guys think
did osta just unlock a major new form
that involves
temporarily assimilating liba into his
body
and what do you think this new form will
look like also
what powers and abilities will the new
asta have
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content right
here on the channel don't forget to
leave a like and a comment
it really helps a lot and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you just haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our
anime opera patrons for making videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect liam thompson
pate heffa
red-haired raven wrythian y-x emperor
otaku
thomas jones spidey life canal and baked
buddhist
finally thank you to our pro-hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky cricket xp joe stanton
rathune de ora very gucci
jessica kayla fond alicia octor hinokami
in water
bonnie parks florian joy and garcia jack
watches anime amanda c
deadly saint high school dxd 73 matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you believe that they add
value to you please consider supporting
us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you